كشف مسؤولا امريكي للجزيره عن حزمه
مساعدات عسكريه جديده لاوكرانيا بقيمه 800
مليون دولار تتضمن قذائف عنقوديه ومدرعات
برادلي وعربات سترايكر وقال المسؤول
الامريكي ان اوكرانيا تعهدت للولايات
المتحده باستخدام القذائف العنقوديه بشكل
مسؤول كما تعهدت كييفل واشنطن بعدم
استخدام القذائف العقوديه في المناطق
الماهوله بالمدنيين ولفتى المسؤول الى ان
اوكرانيا تعهدت كذلك للولايات المتحده
بتوثيق مناطق استخدام القذائف العنقوديه
لتسهيل عمليه نزعها في المستقبل
ينضم الينا من البنتاجون مراسل الجزيره
فادي منصور فادي اذا هذه القنابل
العنقوديه كيف يجري الحديث في اروقه
البنتاغون عن موضوع يعني تزويد اوكرانيا
بها
نعم هذه الحزمه التي سوف يتم الاعلان عنها
في وقت لاحق من اليوم من قبل البيت الابيض
مع تفاصيل من العنوان الابرز فيها كما
اشرت مساله القذائف العنقوديه تحديدا
القذائف من عيار 155 مليمتر وهي قادره على
حمل قنابل عنقوديه مضاده للمدرعات ولكن
ايضا
للافراد وبحكم ان هذه القذائف العنقوديه
او الذخيره العنقوديه تمثل اشكاليه على
الساحه الدوليه حيث ان هناك اكثر من 100
دوله قامت بحظرها المنظمات الدوليه
المعنيه مثل الامم المتحده تنتقد مساله
استخدامها وتدعو الى حظرها بالكامل
الولايات المتحده تدرك ذلك وتدرك ان اقرب
حلفائها الاوروبيين الذين يتشاركون معها
في الحرب في دعم اوكرانيا في حربها مع
روسيا لديهم تحفظات كبيره على هذا الموضوع
وقاموا بحظر هذه الاسلحه ولهذا السبب قال
لنا مسؤول امريكي ان مساله تزويد اوكرانيا
قذائف العنقوديه والتي جرى مساله بحثها
على فتره طويله تاتي في ظل شروط او ضمانات
قدمتها
ابرزها عمليا عدم استخدام هذه القذائف
العنقوديه في المناطق السكنيه الماهوله
بالمدنيين هذه نقطه مهمه للغايه خصوصا ان
القوات الاوكرانيه كانت استهدفت في السابق
مناطق تسيطر عليها القوات الروسيه وفيها
مدنيين واحيانا داخل الاراضي الروسيه
وبالتالي هذه النقطه حساسه للغايه ثانيا
تعهدت كيف بان تستخدم هذه القنابل
العنقوديه بشكل مسؤول وايضا تحديدا مساله
قيام بتوثيق عمليه استخدامها اي اين يتم
استخدامها في المناطق بما ان لديها نسبه
عدم انفجار محدده من اجل تسهيل عمليه
نزعها في المستقبل على قاعده ان اوكرانيا
في نهايه المطاف تقاتل من اجل استعاده هذه
الاراضي وسوف تستخدم هذه الاراضي استخدام
القذائف العنقوديه تمثل مخاطر على سلامه
المدنيين وحتى القوات الاوكرانيه في تلك
المناطق في حال استعادتها وايضا اشار هذا
المسؤول الى ان القنابل العنقوديه التي
سوف يتم تزويد اوكرانيا بها لديها تتسم
بنسبه فشل اي القذائف التي لا تنفجر وعاده
القذائف العنقوديه لديها نسبه كبيره من
عدم الانفجار هي ادنى من
2.35
بالمئه اي من كل مئه قنبله عنقوديه هناك
احتمال اقل من اثنين بالمئه باثنين وخمسه
وثلاثين في المئه منها لا ينفجر وهذا
مستوى تقول الولايات المتحده انه متدني في
نهايه المطاف يذكر هذا المسؤول الامريكي
بان الولايات المتحده لا تقوم بعمل وفق
تعبيره غير مالوف بتزويد اوكرانيا بالقضاء
العنقوديه لاسيما ان روسيا واض استخدامها
في اوكرانيا وايضا القوات الاوكرانيه
تستخدمها لكن يبقى هناك سؤال كبير يتعلق
بالقدره التفجيريه لهذه القنابل التي سوف
يتم تزويد اوكرانيا بها وبالتالي حجم
الضرر الذي يمكن تلحقه وايضا رده الفعل
الدوليه على هذا الموضوع ولا سيما ردت فعل
الجانب الروسي كل ذلك ياتي في سياق اقرار
بان اوكرانيا تواجه تحديات حقيقيه في
مساله الهجوم المضاد ضد الجانب الروسي
وتعول على ان تساهم هذه القذائف في عمليه
تحديدا مساله ضرب القوات الروسيه التي
لديها تحصينات قويه في المناطق التي تحاول
اوكرانيا تحريرها من مراسلنا فادي منصور
شكرا لك